I'm going to talk a little bit about GPRC5D-related adverse events, and particularly about the
management of taste changes, and talk a little bit about some of the work that we've been
doing at J&J with many of you in the community trying to understand this a little bit better.
Before I jump into it, just a disclosure, I'm an employer of Johnson & Johnson.
I head up the Global Medical Affairs Organization at J&J.
So let's talk a little bit about GPRC5D-related targeted therapies for a second, and Rita
and others really talked about this really elegantly.
This idea of targeting GPRC5D, it's relatively novel.
It's a target that J&J had really identified and brought forward, and we were really doing
that for a number of reasons.
One of those is really that idea that it doesn't have that expression across the entire B-cell
lineage.
And we thought that this was going to be really an important opportunity to target something
where we had seen those traditional infectious risks with BCMA-targeting agents.
We were really impressed.
In terms of...
In terms of the efficacy that we initially saw, really raising that bar.
I remember at ASH a couple of years ago, we talked about 60 was the new 20, but talcoidamab
kind of broke that with a 70% response rate.
And I think impressively, right, we still haven't seen the median overall survival in
the original MONUMENTAL-1 study.
But what we have seen are these adverse events, particularly related to targeting GPRC5D.
Oral-related toxicities in particular, dyskousia, dry mouth, and you heard about some of the
some of those in terms of also some of the skin toxicities, too.
Now, one of the things that we have been thinking about from a J&J perspective is where can
you use things like GPRC5D agents, right?
You all saw the great data of MAJESTIC-3 at ASH, but there are other places that we have
been working on developing talcoidamab in both the newly diagnosed setting with MAJESTIC-5,
looking at that in combination to try to improve that induction before transplant.
We've got the MAJESTIC-7 study that's ongoing looking at TANF.
that TAL-DARA-REV versus the MYA regimen in that treatment ineligible setting.
We also have the AMBITION study, which I didn't put up here. And that's actually something
worthwhile talking about because in the AMBITION study, we actually are using talquetamab before
siltacel. So we are using a DVRD followed by a TAL-DARA before you go to siltacel. And we have
a TAL-based regimen after siltacel as well. And we've got tons of translational work,
correlative work in there. So those questions that we were talking about in terms of
how could using a GPRC5 agent before a BCMA, we're going to answer a lot of those questions
because there's tons of correlatives in there. I think it really become clear that using TAL
potentially as a bridge before CARVIC-T is super successful. Karina was talking about this earlier.
If you can get these patients into a PR or a BETA, many of those adverse events that we're
seeing are really mitigated to a significant degree. I think the data that Binod presented
recently showing talquetamab before siltacel was very successful. Monumental 3, soon. You'll see
those results really soon. And I think that'll help us understand how does TAL-DARA work versus
TEC-DARA. We saw that TEC-DARA data and does POM add anything when you add it to that TAL-DARA
regimen? TEC-TAL, what about that in that late line setting, those patients who've seen CD38
or TAL-POM, we'll see that too. And we heard about the redirect study with TEC-TAL. So we've got a
lot of GPRC5D-related regimens that are coming, and addressing this question about oral toxicities
is going to be really important. But just to talk about, again, why we were thinking about GPRC5D,
it was really because of this infection issue. We know that GPRC5D is only expressed really in
those mature B cells, and that is something that we have seen quite regularly. We see lower rates
of severe infections, lower overall rates of infections, and we see B cell recovery in these
patients, which we think is particularly important.
But we've seen these GPRC5-related toxicities. We've seen in many of the patients we get
dyscusia. It happens very quickly, but we do see it resolve. But one of the questions that we're
having is we really need to look at this in a more detailed and a more rigorous way, and that's why
we went about designing a study called TALISMAN. We have seen it, this GPRC5-related toxicities too,
in other agents. So it's not a TAL-QUERDIBAB issue per se, it's really more of a target issue.
But what we've recently learned, and I'll tell you,
this is a learning in the last year or so, is that we've really identified that there is
in the mouth, in this cleft in the tongue, there is this von Ebner's gland. And in that von Ebner's
gland, GPRC5D is present. And so really those dyscusia or those oral toxicities are really an
on-target, but off-tumor GPRC5D-related oral toxicity. So we will see this with other GPRC5-
related agents. So that is really the target. And the question is, is what does that presentation
look like? How does that change over time? And what can we learn from that? Now we've seen a
lot of people doing lots of different things, good oral hygiene, lots of different things in terms of
helping patients with the dysphagia and the dry mouth. And those things are working, but I think
the question is, is what can we do to help prevent it or treat it? And what does that natural history
look like? So we went about designing the TALISMAN study. This is a fully enrolled randomized face
to study. We have group A, which is run contemporaneously with groups B, C, and D.
And that's no prophylaxis. That's your regular treatment of those patients. So we can rigorously
then compare prophylaxis versus no prophylaxis. So all three arms are complete. You'll see the
data from arm A and B at EHA, hopefully, if they give us a presentation, knock wood,
looking at dexamethasone. And then we've also got the oral vergabalin and the clompasin
as well. Now, we also are intending to add a tacrolimus arm to this study too. And we're also
going to study romantomic, because we know romantomic in itself, dual targeting of both
BCMA and GPRC5D has a different binder. And we believe that this binder brings a differentiated
toxicity profile, particularly around adverse events from an oral toxicity perspective.
But what are we seeing or how did we design this? Listen, we're all using CTCA today,
but what we did is we put two particular measures into
this. This STTA measure is a very subjective patient orientated approach where the patient
is really telling you, my taste hasn't changed. I've had some mild loss, moderate, severe,
or complete. But the wet test is the key one. This is purely objective. It is not related to
the physician or the patient. It is very objective in how it's done. And it allows
us really independently assess that. And something I don't think I knew before this is that there are
many different ways in which people taste. And so we can look at all those elements of taste
as well to understand that. And so we've have those assessments in terms of the wet test,
this STTA test as well. But I think one of the key things that we have come out with and found,
and we presented these data, these preliminary data at ASH, is that we are seeing taste recovery
within three months and more taste recovery within seven months. Now, I know there's a lot of
speculation. Maybe that's related to changing from Q2 week to Q4 week, but we don't believe that's
necessarily the case. And what we're trying to do is we're trying to figure out how we're going to
do that. And one of the best ways to kind of look at that and think about that is looking at that
change in taste changes over time. And what you see when you typically go to a Q4 week schedule,
that taste change is already starting to come back. And we see that as you have this deep response,
you see these taste changes. You see that very empirically with this wet test.
And we hear from patients almost immediately at step-up doses, at first full dose, we're
seeing those taste changes. But then we start to see at three months and six months the recovery of
that. And this is really allowing us to understand those taste changes versus controls and versus
those patients where we're going to be looking at those preventative therapies too.
So we are hopeful that we can find something. We have also been looking at some biological
correlives working with Boston Gene to try to really understand from an immune perspective,
what is going on in the mouth? What is going on in those renal glands? What is
happening in the salivary glands as well? Doing biopsies, looking at some immune profiling work,
because we think that there may be some activity in terms of that immune
response. And so we are hoping that we can start to see some engagement with that von Ebner receptor
and that there's some bystander effects where you see these types of changes.
But the good news is we're starting to see it recover. We're seeing that consistently. I think
the question now is what can we do to approach that? And I think just from a J&J perspective,
I was reflecting on the presentations from the very beginning of the meeting. And I was listening
to Tom and everybody else talking about the progress we've made in multiple myeloma. We have
made incredible progress. And it's actually quite amazing to hear us talking about cure,
and being in Miami a couple of weeks ago, defining cure. It's amazing.
But we also have to focus not on treatment, but also helping patients live and live well.
That's so important because patients not living well, that doesn't work. And I know that in